signer 7 à elancourt a bien ouvert ses
portes au public ce mercredi 3 avril 18
mois de travaux auront finalement permis
au cinéma d'être entièrement rénové
le public a pu découvrir des écrans plus
larges de nouveaux fauteuils un accès
aux trois niveaux par l'ascenseur et
enfin une troisième salle qu'en pense
alors les spectateurs à la sortie des
toutes premières séances
depuis le temps qu'on attendait ça
commence à éclore un mois là mais je
trouve que c'est très bien qu'on est
bien installé on a la place
là on est content au niveau du son il
est parfait un niveau du filou et et
puis l'accueil et jolie là maintenant ça
change un petit peu quoi d'abord chez
c'est très beau c'est spacieux si glee
c'est non non c'est très agréable très
averses et je suis contente d'avoir été
une des premières à l'inaugurer moi qui
adore le cinéma un cinéma de proximité
qui a les allures d'un grand
seule la politique tarifaire reste
inchangé 6 euros le billet plein tarif